[Music]
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play surgeon
simulator 2013 okay as soon as I saw
this game I knew I knew that I had to
play and you'll see why in just a bit
yes controls very very good okay so we
need to give this patient a new heart
can we do it well with my skill and
determination I am certain that we can
so let's just see what we've got here ah
I see that my nurse has already opened
the chest cavity oh I guess I will not
be using the saw today I've always
thought that the saw was a little
shallow and pedantic for my taste let us
use the electric saw if you will if you
will if I will and I will oh oh hang on
come back here
yeah these controls are not the most
elegant but they will serve okay as we
carefully make the first incision or the
second Oh
oh god oh god oh god okay all right as
you see okay we are we are exercising
the ribs from the chest cavity so um
yeah oh god oh god okay alright okay
okay so let's um let's throw this off to
the side and let's just forget these
lungs out of here I guess let's see this
one it doesn't look that important okay
let's put that over there let's see get
another lung here and oh oh well next
surgery okay now we've got another
patient here ah they know my reputation
as the world's greatest open heart
surgeon so let's take a look at this
patient hmm oh yes okay good
now let us carefully carefully let go
the clipboard
cute and carefully grab nothing but air
I'm going to take my time on this one
so as to not disturb the patient's
optimal resting pattern um nurse
twenty-seven cc's of Hydra morgue of
Florence lemon please
as I carefully rake the saw across his
gentle brittle ribs this doesn't seem to
be doing much but oh okay all right then
no that's normal that's normal that's
normal that's normal let's just get
those out of there David today don't
need to be there anyway sorry we're not
damaging any vital organs we're gonna be
fine we're gonna be fine okay so I think
that's enough saw for now let's just
grab things out of here and get that get
everything out of here that we can grab
it up grab it up is that still attached
oh not quite okay there we go one lung
down gotcha
all right we're good we're good we're
good two lungs down and the rest of
these ribs can get out of here don't
need them maybe grab that get it out of
here yeah that's good okay still rib
floating here doesn't need to be there
grab it grab it and really just oh oh oh
you say hammer oh good good good
suggestion nurse thank you thank you
that's why you're assisting the greatest
doctor in the land okay all right so
since we got the tray what oh we
actually grab the tray okay all right
since I don't have the hammer I'm going
to have a resort to the saw again which
we will need to excise the arteries of
the heart okay yeah um it's not the best
but you know we can we make do with what
we have you think that's the best choice
doctor of course it's the best choice
I'm a doctor okay let's get back in here
without people questioning oh my
goodness Oh God be very very gentle of
how we apply pressure to the veinous
aureus of the heart and in a gentle
swooping motion we we carefully remove
the excess flesh within the heart cavity
itself and um let's see if we can just
kind of go about our business without
Killian next patient okay so for this
patient since I am the world-renowned
heart transplant surgeon I think I'll
take a different approach I seem to
spend a little too much time getting
everything out of the patient when I
should be focused with putting things in
so to speed up the process I believe
that I will um let's see if I can't
readjust that a bit Bob pick it up again
see here get out of the way all this
excess equipment a nurse remember uh
remind me next time to get all the extra
equipment out of the way early on that
way I don't need it
let's see you need to get this into a
position where I can grab it
appropriately just like that yes
excellent and I've got a scalpel no no
what no no no no ha ha get back here
ah save my radio good I don't know what
I'd do without my tunes all right so now
that we've got the hammer carefully
placed over the chest auric cavity we
are going to carefully apply some force
to remove the bonus aratus struggle oh
my goodness what is going on something
has um spontaneously happened as was
expected the lung has vacated the chest
cavity Oh
okay yes um we are doing well we're
doing well just get on that out there
and as you can see the hammer is very
good at removing all of the patient's
blood which we are going to carefully
control now the heart is nearly
completely exposed as you can see and uh
we are going to just pick the
unnecessary ribs you know there are a
lot of ribs in the human body and over
90% of them are unnecessary did you know
yes they are yeah okay so now that the
heart is properly exposed we are going
to grab it no still clearly got the ribs
there's a lot more ribs to clear out
here and just get them out of here
get them out of here while the patient
still is alive
you know open-heart surgeries have a 99%
mortality rate just so you know so I'm
not I'm not a poor surgeon my mortality
rate is 98% actually so I'm very good so
just once you're in grab the heart with
both with all fingers and just yank back
and forth until you get it out of there
just really ignore all the bones in your
radius sedona and just flail around
until the heart gets out of there okay
all right so now that we've thoroughly
massage the heart let's um uh-huh here's
the other heart yep just where I
expected it to be and drag that into
place just toss it oh no what the heart
go what the heart go what about heart
know where to go okay um people all
notice people won't notice because this
guy's now gonna have a crazy base up in
his chest cavity as we just sweep
everything into Oh God
oh god what am i doing people gonna
realize that I'm a fraud I got a fraud
I'm not a fraud I'm not a fraud I'm not
a I'm not a fraud I'm not a fraud duh
oh okay all right so um things don't
seem to be going so ideally anymore I'm
gonna lose my medical license dog stop
crazy crazy of course it's right I'm
gonna duck
of course it's best I'm a doctor not a
doctor I'm a doctor I know I'm doing I'm
a damn doctor
bethink you can tell me what to do they
think they know did they think they
could tell me what to do huh get back
you can't ask I'm a fine it's all your
fault you bastard
tell your [ __ ] a good age God now if you
I do the heart first without taking
yours the other heart dies nobody that's
how they get it that's how that got it
that's how they do it
no Java they'll have big city doctors
they take it tell me what to do
thought there big city knowledge they
don't know they don't know hey no no
it's good for me no no no I got my
medical I get that Nicaragua they think
I know it's best I know it's best no no
no no dig it Irina get the proper
leverage for that saw and just hahaha
you think you could know you think you
know what it takes
you think you know the pressures of a
doctor go through 18 years of medical
school and they still won't give you
their license save you okay alright calm
down calm down buddy calm down
but now what's to be calm down calm you
think I'm calm
and you think I've come well of course
I'm coming I don't even know what tool
this is but I'm gonna use it to the best
of my ability get to judge the thoracic
cavity into the lungs areolas the
nipples the penis the vagina that's all
I know that's all I'm ever gonna know
you think you
okay all right so we managed to kill
five patients in record time for five
patients there was the other one in the
alley well okay all right well okay so
if you want a brutally murder your own
patients save a brutally murder if you
want to kick he'll kill your own
patients click the link in the
description below I'll take you through
the surgery room in the back alley of my
van so thank you so much for watching
click the annotation hey thank you see
you in the next room search for video
bye bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]